where
they're from here why okay
why
come you're here okay it looks much
better say that life is ours
that's good
[Music]
you want me to sit here yeah sit right
there oh no
okay so this is Five Nights at Freddy's
sister location do you know what this is
um sister location must be looking for
sister
yes yeah yeah
you know you're not wrong
I think if you ask matpat that's
completely 100 right there you go and
click new game new game and click yeah
click this one yeah okay on the left
this one have you ever used a mouse
before no never
mm-hmm
welcome to the first day of your
exciting new career whether you were
approached at a job fair read our hat
and screws bolts and hairpins or if this
is the result of a dare we welcome you
please enter your name as seen above the
keypad this cannot be changed later so
Mike just be careful
Mike yeah you're right you're right what
well done okay oh M typed it what
um okay I'm gonna type m
what are you where are you can you see a
honey that's right later oh right there
oh my goodness
this is tough honey it's tough yeah but
you got it oh I got it twice good yeah
yeah that's good oh no no no no am i r
go Mark
[Music]
oh come on uh-huh why you make my life
so terrible it's a game it's supposed to
be tough oh my gosh you get this wrong
oh Monster's gonna jump scare you okay
oh you got it I I don't know you got it
I don't know now what should I do okay I
think you gotta hit enter where's the
enter it's on C on the bottom in the
middle oh you got it you got it okay you
got it you got it
okay truth be told it didn't matter no
matter what you put in it would have not
let you
that's just how it is
but now this Begins the experience
of sister location Five Nights at
Freddy's sister location
using that bright red and obvious button
yeah I know
I know how to push the button should I
do it again no no the doors opened
the door in front of you opened
this one no the big door oh okay hi now
what uh what should I do okay so move
your mouse until your little mouse
clicker turns into an arrow move it down
just find around there you go see it and
go back up and oh see go in yeah okay
good
w
yeah w-o
faster right in most games shift is the
sprint button
which means you go back you are now in
the library control module it's actually
a crossover now it's going to get real
tough showrooms now let's get started
with your daily tasks
oh I didn't see that I wasn't looking at
that what's going to happen oh my
goodness I only see this in the middle
they're all looking at button on the
elevated keypads to your left press
something keypad so these buttons lit up
over on the left here oh I'll press the
light the light at the top okay
okay uh oh it looks like ballora doesn't
feel like dancing let's give her some
motivation press the red button now to
administer a controlled shock this one
maybe that will put the spring back in
her step yeah
so you just get one of the monsters a
shot again an electric shock like a
cattle prod bam
pretty cool right
light again okay I'm sorry well there
she is I see something here yeah Aurora
is feeling like her that's ballora
is a ballerina you used to want to be a
ballerina right this is the fun time
honestly we're fun times oh your mouse
to the right all the way right all the
way oh okay and the light yeah oh
monsters my fun time foxy is taking the
day off let's motivate Funtime foxy with
a controlled shock of course
you might be enjoying that a little too
much
come on
where are you coming at girl try the
light
and then we'll try another control Josh
sure
here you go oh she's coming I see a
little bit
I don't know I didn't see it I see it
right there yeah there we go you're
right you're right one time foxy is
perfect working perfect in front of you
is another vent shaft crawl through it
to reach the circus Gallery control
module well done that's part of the
maintenance task of being in responsive
or being responsible for these
animatronics you gotta you gotta take
care of them you got to make sure that
they're okay they like a shipping shot
it's like energy shot
I mean yeah sure
electrical some kind of stimulation
but are they like masochists or is it
just because they're robots
I don't know you have to ask them but
they like certain thing okay okay well
you're done in this room so go in the
bottom okay let's go into the vent again
this way click on it first and then
you'll yeah you'll use the keyboard
doubly and shift way yes let's get going
okay on the other
side's polite and see what baby is up to
uh-huh left or right oh here you go
light
nobody nobody you know what to do now
I'm gonna give you some juice
electrical juice
[Music]
sure
more light and more
come on you're a little impatient here
but okay I like it I like a pushing
button
I can do this job all day long
come on
oh do I need to put a little mush
yeah if you could increase the voltage
maybe that would help how can I increase
I
[Music]
don't weld otherwise
please leave using the vent behind you
and we'll see you again tomorrow no I
failed yeah it's okay because you didn't
shock hard enough probably
ah
it's my finger I got a little weaker I'm
getting old right
[Music]
ensure your hands yeah I cannot push a
button anymore oh how can I be the let's
player that I am without these I'm
doomed oh you might as well go back you
failed this time but that's okay how can
I fail pushing buttons you I don't know
that's my specialty I know I practice
all my life pushing button pretty much
it
like slot machine
well you didn't do so good now
you know this okay we're gonna go back
in and it's gonna be similar to last
time so just remember all the lessons
you learned that was like a tutorial
think of that as just like a beginner
course on how to do what you need to do
here this one is going to be putting
your skills into experience
it seems that you had some trouble with
the keypads I see what you were trying
to type and I will auto correct it for
you thank you thank you for choosing
angsty teams you're welcome are we going
down yeah we're going down you're in an
elevator
sorry night two night two okay remember
what you do yeah I think so okay we're
gonna go night two and do button button
good almost stopped oh you know the
routine
yeah
whatever now you're here if you want
goodbye button okay you remember yeah
yeah yep okay and you're in the event
of course W and shift here good good
yeah okay okay let's start with you
remember what to do here oh yeah okay
who's behind there
there's a lot of talking going on there
they like to talk you like talk they
like sure things to do you have nothing
to nobody to entertain you so I'll
entertain you I'll talk to you all day
long
is anybody there come on now
no I shock you oh I
said two heads right
here
do you wish you like motion more you
know somebody is working right now yeah
you can see I can hear the noise do you
want something do you want something do
you want something
I heard grumbling
that's it are you done okay Funtime foxy
make sure he's ready for showtime
tomorrow all right
sometimes epoxy on the right side okay
see
oh whoa I see foxy would you like to
have a little great great great great
I heard that great there seems to have
been a problem with the voice
synthesizer default settings have been
restored please proceed through the vent
ahead of you to Circus baby's Auditorium
sure let's get going okay W and shift
here yes yeah
you gotta click on it first
so where would you rank like the
scariness of this one versus the other
ones
unknown are you scared
I need more excitement control shock
baby come out
oh let's try another controlled shock
okay here you go
oh no there seems to be a power
malfunction that is affecting our
ability to properly motivate baby please
stand by while I reboot the system thank
you I will be offline momentarily during
this process various other systems may
be offline as well such as security
doors vet locks and oxygen
commencing system restart
okay
maintenance vent opened
well I don't recognize you you are new
yes I am I remember this scenario
however okay
it's a strange thing to want to do to
come here I know curious what events
would lead a person to want to spend
their nights in a place like this good
question willingly maybe curiosity
maybe ignorance
yes both under the desk someone before
you crafted it into a hiding place
really it worked for him okay I
recommend that you hurry though
why you will be safe there just try not
to make eye contact no eye contact it
will be over soon okay
you better hide I better hide otherwise
we know what I'll be killed right yeah
exactly so you better hide I'll hide
you're like now how how here yeah let's
go
okay okay
under the days you're hiding under the
desk yes what should I do just hi there
uh oh right there well you might want to
do something while you're hiding okay
what should I do
oh maybe look around and see if there's
anything that can help you okay what is
it that's a wall
that was some convenient text if you
read it
okay over on the left oh
okay grab here and click into my
driveway
yeah it's a cover here
putting a cover over you to hide
yourself okay am I covered no not yet
it's all the way there you go click and
drag yeah there you go I cannot click
you're good you're covered okay I'm
coming all right
I'd wear
why again you are hidden yeah
something Mommy
I can't hear
huh
nobody's home
[Music]
I'm sure it's nothing I'm sure you're
fine
I'm sure I'm okay
you cannot see me I'm hiding real good
yeah there's no holes or anything in
your hiding spot yeah right
no
no why is it moving oh they're opening
it oh no I'm gonna close it oh okay okay
close it close it you're doing it close
what close it close it put it back put
it back not that way no close it close
it wait the way you did before close it
close the thing you have a big opening
here it's open close it how can I close
you're closing it right now this one you
are doing it
you're clicking and dragging remember to
click and drag Okay click and drag click
and drag don't let go
[Applause]
okay a drag where
[Music]
imagine your hand is on something and
you're trying to put it there oh
you didn't know that was a door
oh oh cool this way there you go big in
here okay okay
hard I'm hiding and when they try to
open it oh and then I close it they're
trying to close I see I have to fight
they're gonna open it
then I close this way right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
I okay my hand
oh no
oh
that's scary oh
oh my gosh
get ready this is really
really get ready you know oh my God
that is weird I didn't see that before I
know I know now I know what the hole is
for I was wondering why is that hole
there all right but be careful they're
gonna start moving they're they're
moving it
there we go
yeah yeah just like that keep holding
hold strong
[Applause]
all right but it's not over yet oh cool
you did great just hold it hold that you
hold that
hold that 20.
there's no eyes peeking through the door
looking for me I said no way
yes yes yes
[Music]
all right
you're so close you're very close yeah
very strong
flaming on my finger okay but one more
time you got because you know how to do
it now right now I got it I know how
their eyes were such a scary thing I
ever said oh yeah
oh
don't let go don't let go oh
good job
[Music]
oh my God
I don't know why it's just
but he's not worth that
spook
y it is spooky eyes oh it's moving oh no
there we go good it's good that's good
come on my life is depend on this oh
come on should I move it this way you
can yeah oh it's good oh yeah it's gone
very good okay sounds good keep going
push it all the way to the right oh I
think okay but that was good Instinct
yeah so you can should I keep holding or
let go yeah yeah you can keep going
unless you want to check for uh okay
let's go take boys
[Music]
oh he's moving
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah good good
good right there yeah
no you don't have to let go you don't
have to let go on the mouse oh no you
don't have to unclick oh
dear life oh save me save me
oh yeah
there you go am I okay
they might come back should I check the
eyes
or dead eyes come on oh that's a
scariest thing oh Scoopy
oh no his eyes are they here looking
when you're guide they might be going
back online he is going to tell you that
he was unsuccessful oh this is what you
must restart the system manually
manually he will then tell you to crawl
through ballora Gallery as fast as you
can to watch the breaker room okay if
you follow his instructions you will die
ballora will not return to her stage
anymore
she will catch you
the power will be restored shortly when
you crawl through ballora gallery go
slowly she cannot see you and can only
listen for your movement
become louder she is growing near
listening for you
did you hear the instructions and be
still oh thank you for your patience it
seems
you restart it automatically you will
need to restart the power system
manually but there's one more thing
after the primary control module before
you can leave okay press s on the
keyboard to go back
okay okay all right so this last thing
now this is very important
that what what the lady who was talking
to you told you
the man voice is going to tell you to go
as fast as possible remember listen you
will die
I see it the other way yeah exactly just
like some children in a moment this is
going to open up early so remember I
said ballora was the ballet dancer I
know so what should I do go slowly
I'm gonna give you the instructions
about this
at the end of this dark hallway
is a door that you need to get to you
can't turn on the lights but if you
listen
to
music
now when that music gets louder that
means ballora is close and you need to
stop moving
W same as before W and shift go forward
you can go forward quickly with shift or
you can go forward just slowly with just
w
if you have music stop
now go slowly or fast I don't know I
can't hear the music it's up to you no
music
I'm going slowly now see that
I hear music
first stop first stop
is it music loud
no
it's quiet if it gets quiet and goes
away you can go
but just be very careful
you okay
oh my God they get you you all right
okay we're done we're done oh my God
we're done okay that I just wanted to
see that part is hard that is a very
difficult part because you gotta listen
super carefully and then you gotta keep
your volume up and you gotta like really
tune in oh my god oh but that was well
done you did the other part I didn't
know if you were gonna get through that
at least oh my God I got you good you
know that eyes yeah yeah yeah I was here
in trying to go through there without
the code and oh my God
well you did great sister location is
one is probably a lot of people's
favorite Five Nights at Freddy's game
because it's so different it's so unique
and so stylized and so memorable in some
of the things
um what do you think of this one
compared to the other ones
oh
I like original one original one this
one seemed to have
like actually
[Applause]
those eyes peeking through and I was
just trying to go as as quiet I can then
I didn't expect something
yeah that was really but you still like
the first one the best yeah okay because
the oldies no better and you know what I
mean well all right well thank you for
another year of playing Five Nights at
Freddy's yeah with Mom applier yeah you
can find Mama plier on Instagram real
mama pliers yeah real mama player and
you can follow for way too many updates
about uh my life and your drawings and
art and stuff like that yeah
and thank you for supporting us
from North Korea thank you everyone who
watched the documentary hopefully we can
get that documentary to you and another
way to watch it very soon but for those
of you there for the moment thank you
very much hopefully the book will be
published soon soon yes so and if you
guys want more of this let us know in
the comments yeah happy New Year Happy
New Year
[Applause]
okay well thank you thank you as always
we'll see you
bye-bye